[Music]
in two Broke news tooth poor submitted
by pls stand up please stand up ago
please stand up a woman is suing her
fiance for moral and financial damages
after he left her at the altar oh can
you sue for that I guess you can sue for
anything for the wedding if it was all
planned out that she spent a whole bunch
of money yeah and then he just backed
out on it that's messed up man
what kind of a woman was she for him to
run away like a little [ __ ]
pump your brakes bro but I do agree what
type of woman was she she could have
been a sweetheart he could be just
commitment issues exactly he freaked out
we were just playing the the opposite of
good right now all right okay thank you
very much I appreciate that there it is
don't try to change my thought I just
want to know what drove him to go crazy
we're all the best man that would have
been the best and everyone was there
prior yeah it's already everyone oh not
none of his family showed up so they
knew that's not that's what I meant like
sometimes like the guy already gives a
warning and I saw all of his side is
like already not there how about that we
just cancel the wedding I know just say
like Hansel I can't do it don't have
everyone waste ur [ __ ] time he's been
yeah he's like I don't think we should
do it anymore and then she's like [ __ ]
you or God do it you son of a [ __ ] cuz
I feel his cold feet like no one knew
mm-hmm I knew that's a little bit better
because it's just on him like he pushed
out or whatever or maybe that girl's a
crazy-ass [ __ ] but it doesn't it
doesn't matter but if he had enough like
guts in him to tell his family and so he
was gonna call it off but he just
conveniently didn't tell hers that's
kind of [ __ ] up yeah
or maybe it was a revenge Oh imagine how
she felt though dude
God you went to have a stitch party
without me yeah saying years of therapy
after that [ __ ] right that's a nightmare
again yeah yeah so this oh yeah this
takes place in Thailand oh it's a Tyler
yeah what what do you know why people
like seen the Godfather like at a nice
you know like a Catholic Church oh yeah
well no it's different because of God's
voice I sharks for some reason palm
trees the Thai [ __ ] bar that's where
they're getting the headed married that
the whole seemed like I patient like a
big-ass Cathedral of each in ladies and
white and their dress is like 20 feet
long
and immediately now it's a girl with
[ __ ] gold rings around her neck and a
job somewhere yeah and the guy one more
toy shark sticker down a banana tree the
change completely what to paint it a
little bit this is the wedding this is
all like that too far oh yeah that's
good that's embarrassing
yeah so what happened here so 26 year
old groom named Boone Ying oh you got
pony
dude that's like he wasn't his
girlfriend for six years he was with his
girlfriend for six years his
girlfriend's name is a Rooney 24-degree
name a Rooney a Rooney ruin your life
Luo yang away the day before the wedding
the couple met with the bride's parents
to make final preparations for the
wedding and at that time the groom
showed no symptoms of cold feet or
anything but severely itching and sweat
no signs of cold feet is that better
David flu-like sound like other diseases
funny to me just hilarious yeah so then
they so the morning of the wedding the
wedding was supposed to start at 6:00
a.m.
goddamn I know that's why he Jolla
Southeast Asians can't wake up at 6:00
and then so seeing that Boone yang was
running late the family the Bryan and
her family tried calling him if I know
what was going on he answers the phone
he tells them that everything was okay
but that he wanted to postpone the
wedding for a few hours because he
wasn't gonna be able to make it in time
he's Thai he's running late he's on Thai
time how are you gonna have a wedding at
6:00 a.m. so then they've changed that
they called everyone and they told then
that the wedding would be at 9:00 a.m.
instead and so finally the hours passed
it was past 9:00 the groom still didn't
show up neither did his family and
shuttle Rooney you started trying was
trying to call him again along with her
family they were trying to find him he
would not answer the phone anymore and
then so mmm finally they traveled to his
hometown apparently they live far away
from each other and so her and her
family go to his town and he was jacking
off there was no late
I'm pumped up there was no one there the
groom and his parents fled and so they
leave all their belongings yeah leaves
yeah so then later they find out the
bride's family finds out that Boone Yang
and his parents I couldn't afford to pay
the dowry which was 200 baht or six
thousand twenty-five dollars in cash and
5 baht weight of fold oh they just
couldn't pay that and so that's the
reason why he found Thunder that's so
it's over money yeah it's over
embarrassment yeah this is even worse
why they not the whole town knows that
there's a fleeting ass family yeah
apparently he planned to raise the money
but he felt to do it before the wedding
and so Oh ty time you call it no why
don't you just marry for love that's
just there oh that's a tradition there
yeah I don't know that I do know I don't
know you know yeah and so now the you're
worth a brick of gold a [ __ ] Lama and
a red carpet what happened to his love
is she that's an American invention
that's right love is an American
invention mm-hmm well it's actually a
British invention and if you trace our
current concept of love and the way that
it's shaped it's uh I think from a
female writer what I feel in my heart
what death no love how do you explain
that
that wasn't a British invention it's in
my heart our concept of what it is the
construct of a romantic movie and what
is romance how is it expressed everyone
has love but the way that it's expressed
in the Western world
yeah love exists within Asians right but
they don't express it the same it's not
that Asians are loved list less they
make your food it's different love
languages yeah yeah so now our unni's
family is
and get the groom and his family to pay
1000 baht for the wedding party and that
they still owed about twenty-two
thousand baht for the food and
twenty-two thousand twenty two thousand
twenty two thousand by which they eat
$12 mango rice and Oh sticky rice and
mango is so good but it's only seasonal
why the twenty thousand is about one
hundred and sixty four dollars dude fine
I'll pay for the [ __ ] food but you
give me all the goddamn food that's what
has to happen you have a poor Rooney
there saying that she was she started
crying so much [ __ ] she almost fainted
and that she was so embarrassed the Tai
Chi is in the most pleasant day in the
world she dodged a good one though
because if he can't pay the dowry he's
he's gonna bounce when he can't pay rent
kids know right so he's just gonna run
away his whole family's like a family of
Runaways yeah so they're saying that she
was so embarrassed as we stood up on her
wedding day that she'd quit her job it
was not any sense I mean to you but like
out there it looked like it was like
this little village and [ __ ] everyone
talks so they're probably gonna make fun
of her now like look at this [ __ ] hag
nobody wants to marry her you know
that's not true it's just cuz he
couldn't look for he couldn't know you
know but you know how the town likes
small [ __ ] mind
hey you can't call small town Thai
people town minded what small minded I
didn't I'm just saying like when you
come from a small town there's not much
else to do but to just like [ __ ] yeah
man she should just like bamboo trees
like all Thai people do yeah that's what
they do every day yep I stayed in a
hmong village in the border of Thailand
and Myanmar and it was a very fun
experience because there were chickens
all over the place
pigs all over the place and opium fields
all over the
and I really liked it there and the
point that I'm trying to get to is the
village actually look like that like
they had like you get wood and make up a
hole with tarp and all kinds of [ __ ]
such a wedding a place
yeah I pictured Mexico because all I did
was go on mission trips yep so I need to
go to the other parts next good all I
saw was stray dogs and kids that made me
cry all the time
and gunshots in the middle of the night
that's the BA home yeah but we were
there to do missionary work and build
homes and stuff because it was so set
these kids to man day some they're like
stupid spiritual like there was like
these rabid dogs coming around the shed
and these dogs look like they're gonna
bite me in delightful right you afraid
if God is there for you but that's crazy
I remember they may horchata for me and
then I was scared to drink it because I
was like I'm gonna yeah cuz they made it
with of course they're not gonna use the
tap water right they use bottled water
I'm just so [ __ ] racist right I think
like everything in Tijuana is gonna give
me diarrhea and kill me so I was like
mom died in diarrhea bottled water is
fine it's just that they had to wear
flip-flops and [ __ ] and some of the kids
did it and they got [ __ ] worms or
[ __ ] I got hella diarrhea from like this
taco shop cuz uh when I went to Rosarito
everyone was like when you drink it out
of the Mexican Coke don't put your lips
on it cuz they recycle the glass nothing
[ __ ] that so I drank it like this and
then a half way back up the border have
a crazy diarrhea is that the longest
wedding today
I love I know it's so weird because the
only thing I could equate to the Thai
culture is my tie just because I love
their warrior sense dude they're so it's
a pie that has more than muy Thai
and ladies that house movie man got one
[ __ ] time long y'all bak dude but
just that this set part of that cost I
mean obviously you're loosely of
Thailand dude like the history there's
amazing like the buildings or whatever
but I just like watching people do muy
Thai and Tre so [ __ ] brutal rule it's
Mia cuz it's knees and elbows yeah you
want to spend and they died in their 30s
they do they do yeah
dirt they don't live very long like most
of them are orphans and they they
trained these orphans from a very young
age and they their career is like hard
they have to fight a lot just to survive
and eat and then in their mid-30s they
die or maybe 40 if you're lucky
well there's ruin my whole day
[Music]
[Music]